[Applause]
here's
an interesting story they said that uh
amc is bringing back um
movies i think it's this week and
they're gonna be 15 cents to honor the
same price that they were in 1927 or
something like that yeah
and they're putting out like classics
like back to the future is one of them
right a couple others i think i think uh
star wars
are movies done i think that's the real
question
i don't think so what do you mean by
movies i think
movie theater sorry not movies movie
theaters i think movie theaters are done
dude i don't think they come back
didn't they recently get rid of some law
that
uh prevented studios from opening their
their own theaters
did they i believe so interesting so
that's crazy they even had a law
yeah now you're gonna probably see like
just big studios have
just their movies so it's a tricky thing
right because
the issue with putting a film out
directly to vod which is video on demand
where you just buy a pay-per-view
essentially
is it becomes incredibly easy to
download it and then just repost it on
one of those like torrent websites
how you watch a bunch of movies on those
torah websites right thanks nation
say what thanks for stitching we got you
doctor um
so you can't do it if you're in a
and also another thing is if you watch a
movie on vod
you download it and then four of you and
your family watch it
that's one price one ticket for four
people to watch
instead of one ticket fifteen bucks for
one person one fifty dollars
exactly so they're going to lose an
incredible amount of money if it goes to
vod
but if it doesn't if it goes to vod
not only are they going to lose money
they can't fit the budget of these films
if you're only making one quarter of
what you used to make you
all of a sudden cannot make the next
avatar or
jurassic park or any of these like 200
300 million dollar films yeah
you can't make avengers you can't make
avengers
if you're vod because it won't make
enough money right
it just unless they find a system where
they can completely block it from being
uh i guess like stripped from the
internet and if you really want to do it
you could do it just like they did
bootlegs back in the day you could have
a video camera set up in your apartment
framed up to your tv instead of having
to find an asian lady on the subway to
buy the dvd
it's a website that has it right up
there that's it so it's like
it's it's really it really could change
the way that films are made and and
drastically reduce budgets and why why
would they not go to movie theaters
i think because of corona people aren't
going to movie theaters and i think
yeah and i think once you get
comfortable not going like once you
accept that you could just watch
something at home and enjoy it and have
your
food whatever you want to have get your
delivery i mean like i love watching
movies at home
i never used to do it i loved the movie
experience it was like a fun
date night because i felt like staying
at home watching the movie wasn't
as an exciting as an exciting thing to
do with my girl
but now that i'm cool just doing that
and that's an acceptable date
i can't see people going back to movies
is there like a virtual reality movie
experience they could give you
like even if you're just virtually going
to the theater and paying less part of
the reason why i bought the oculus
to recreate that movie theater feel
mm-hmm
that's what i was thinking when i was
thinking about vr like like it's dope
and you could not see the person like
next to you or whatever or their avatar
of the person next to you
but it's still it's not that comfortable
you've still got this heavy [ __ ] sitting
on your face maybe 10 to 15 years
but no um driving movie theaters are
becoming a lot more popular i can see
that
and that's as like a kind of novelty
thing it's just in new york we can't do
that i also think
if you do that once or twice you're
gonna be like i'm good but you need a
car though
sure you know what i'm saying like don't
get me wrong it looks like a fun thing
to do
but all these new yorkers that would go
to movies they don't have a car
it was a cheap fun thing to do as a kid
you have 10 bucks you go to a movie
theater there's like this
sense of independence and freedom that
you have now that [ __ ] is done
i do not see movie theaters recovering
from this and i'm curious how the
[ __ ] we're gonna have films are they
gonna charge fifty dollars
for the new avengers yeah i think it's
gonna be the same as like a pay-per-view
fight because let's be honest
avengers end game we would have all paid
a hundred dollars a ticket
we would pick i was more excited for end
game than i was for any recent boxing
match
or mma fight so if end game comes out in
six months would you not go to a theater
and see it
it depends you know what it might have
to be it might have to be the expensive
ticket
what's the movie theater you like that's
like very like a much better experience
like i have your ipod
i pick or something i pick there's a
movie theaters they have the reclining
chairs and the [ __ ]
i think that's you're gonna charge way
more and it's gonna be for that like
this is an upgraded experience i'm
living in luxury it's like flying first
class but for movies
and then you pay 30 40 whatever maybe
but it's like no but this is like it's
like going to a fancy dinner
i know i could get this at home but i'm
paying for all of this also how are you
going to be comfortable with the mask on
it is not comfortable this is all
wearing a [ __ ] mask because i was
flying and i had to like do stop
overflight so the whole day i wore a
mask
it's awful it [ __ ] sucks it sucks i
get it i'm gonna do it
but it's just uncut you're out of breath
the whole day it just sucks
people are gonna take it off in a movie
theater and then that's the problem yeah
one person takes it off it's a rap yeah
they're gonna do the glass [ __ ] probably
that's probably what they're gonna do
like they're gonna do the glasses you
buy tickets in groups of twos or fours
like comedy shows they got the glass
thing
cause they know they gotta they make
more money on concessions and popcorn
than
tickets probably like if you're the
movie theater yeah
so they'll figure out some kind of
situation where you can eat and drink
and whatever and then i think once
corona is
like we have the vaccine then i think
it's gonna be morphed into like um
this is an experience that's like
luxurious almost
big-ass screen you might have a big tv
at home you don't get a 400 inch
screen no that's true they just are they
just need to find a way
to enter the uh i don't know
movies we're always on the precipice of
the future right the idea of a movie
theater even like connecting
sound and video like all you always look
for film and you're like wow this is the
newest technology this is the newest
graphics these are the newest like
experiences that you can have visually
and now the method in which they deliver
it
it may be antiquated they haven't found
a way to monetize the future of what
films are you need to deliver to our
house maybe we'll go to the movie
theater as well
but you got to find a way to deliver to
us yeah and we have vod
but we can get around it too quick i
think virtual reality might be
the way maybe why would people be less
inclined to go to a movie but still
inclined to go to a restaurant
i don't think people are as inclined to
go to a restaurant i think they'll go
outside
you know and don't get wrong i have but
like you're in there
in a restaurant there's some separation
between other people i really think it's
gonna be the same thing it's gonna be
like fine dining not any restaurant fine
dining yeah and it's women
women are gonna drive it they like
having the experience of going out and
doing these things and
getting dressed up or whatever i think
in the same way that's why i think it'll
be more luxurious it's the experience of
like
oh we're just going out i'm getting
dressed up we're paying money for
tickets somebody's bringing us food
whatever
i think that's how it has to go because
i think women care about this [ __ ] more
than we do i also my suspicion is that
most of the country is not as scrupulous
about corona
as we are in new york you know what i
mean like yeah
in new york like those things might
suffer but like kansas city
like you think they're gonna not go to i
was in aspen right yeah
super low cases like nothing there
right right mandatory mask
mandate outside
that's crazy you can't walk around town
without a mask and people come up and
stop you
security guards police officers they go
you have to wear a mask or else you're
going to be fine i think his point is
middle america aspen
might be geographically middle america
but it's like
socioeconomically not middle america
fair you know i mean people with money
probably tend to be more liberal etc
kansas city
like any of these florida the whole
state pretty much like
right that's a different level of even
in pennsylvania no one was like
wearing mess yeah we went into
restaurants and like you had to wear the
mask to the table and then take it off
yeah that's how it is everywhere you
wear the mask table and then you can eat
it yeah
but with the movie theater you're gonna
have to keep the mask on
it's an unpleasant experience and also
with the movie
you don't need to be in the [ __ ]
theater the theater never did anything
for me
the theater is just a barrier of entry
for me to see the theater is the place
where the movie is exactly right
so now that we've eliminated that
barrier of entry now that you can
actually give that to me in my home
why don't you just give it to me in my
home because i make less money so
you have to find a way to monetize home
and maybe what they'll do to make up for
it we start to see a lot more like
integrated advertising in films
you know there's like stupid yeah yeah
yeah like whenever watch any james bond
movie and you'll notice like when he's
holding the steering wheel
dude like well not only aston martin if
the shot is over his right shoulder
both of his hands will be on the right
side of the steering wheel like nobody
drives
like this at two and three yeah but
they're here so you could see the watch
the amiga
ah right so it's like maybe you start
seeing a lot more of that and they try
to monetize through
advertising yeah but it can't go on like
it
i don't see it do you really see people
packing into movie theaters anymore
no i i think they'll just do what
restaurants do and comedy clubs and just
have those barriers and now those movie
theaters
are making half the amount of money
that's not enough to profit a lot will
close down
a lot will close down i don't think it
goes away i don't think movies are done
right i think they will adapt also the
thing about of course of course no doubt
yeah i just mean like
the way in which we watch them they have
to be able to deliver it the opening
night thing that we're like
when you went to go see avengers and
there's no [ __ ] seats available
yeah it's so great that's not around for
another year or two
probably at least like we're not
comfortable doing that for a while yeah
they're just gonna have to be at like
50 capacity they're gonna have to have
barriers up and i i
see the movie theaters like i pick are
the ones that will be able to
that's why i think yeah because they
already serve um overpriced food so it's
like
you go there for that experience all
they have to do is just put a little
barrier right next to the pocket they're
already kind of socially distanced
because yeah
yeah to his point of overpriced you know
you're overpaying going in
but it's about the experience yeah i got
this big-ass screen i got this pod it's
me and my girl it's romantic
we got privacy it's let's go and i think
the
big there will be a few of those big
screen old type movie theaters i'm sure
but like
as we knew them but i don't i think it's
going to be more of the ipic you're
paying for the experience
beyond just big screen loud sound yeah
i wonder if this creates a pretty cool
um opportunity for
new filmmakers in the same way that like
youtube created an opportunity for
shorter form content shows right like
people watch this show
as if it's a tv show yeah like we've
created our own talk show
essentially right they put it on their
tv and then put it on their tv and they
watch it
so for whatever reason that never
trickled into scripted tv
it triggered trickled into sketch like
you see sketch on youtube you see sketch
on instagram that kind of stuff but like
the scripted tv stuff long form you
haven't really seen it
and film it never really touched it and
i wonder if
the comfort with video on demand i
wonder if we
are comfortable watching what is it the
princess stand out under the king
instead of whatever
i rented it right so it's like i wonder
if we get more and more comfortable with
renting these things on
apple or amazon or whatever different
you know streaming service you use
if new filmmakers who are unattached
right could create their own pieces and
then put them up there with much more
much less like a scrutiny you know if
somebody's like oh my film's going
straight to
you know apple tv or whatever where you
can download it you'd be like oh nobody
bought your film
right but now we're at a place where at
least with stand up
yeah i put my special on youtube it's
like oh yeah that's where you go watch
stand up yeah
i wonder if that happens to movies now
and then it gives opportunities to some
like filmmakers who never got a shot in
hollywood but they're [ __ ] sick and
they could kill it
and now that barrier of entry is much
less yeah yeah i think that i think that
was starting already yeah it was for the
most part
i'm only paying for movies at the
theater if they're like
movies i would want to see at the big
time yeah big big budget special effects
superhero movies are perfect that's why
they were so bankable yeah because
people will pay for this
furious game [ __ ] x man i remember
joker i was i remember
being surprised like yo joker made a lot
of money at the movie theater
and it doesn't seem like the kind of
movie that you could have put that [ __ ]
right to the crib yeah and we would all
watch joker at the crib
yeah yeah i don't know i'm really
curious to see what happens with
cinema man the next few years post
corona is going to be like
because these fascinating these you know
and we'll move on but like
these companies what are they called
these like studio these film houses i
don't know what you've heard of them
studios film house whatever they are
they gotta be [ __ ] themselves
because they have these movies made yeah
like
the newest who's the guy that made the
dark knight rises and all those that's
for no nolan
has a new movie called i think tenet or
something like that it's with uh
denzel washington's kid right and
that's probably 100 million dollar
budget 200 million
budget he has a finished movie yeah with
nowhere to [ __ ] put it
so they're just sitting on 200 million
dollars spent
waiting for a time when they can recoup
that's a lot of money to wait on